yeah welcome to another video and I'm
playing some guy from Mexico okay let's
mix it up the Dutch okay I get you for
the storm gambit this is an interesting
way to to combat the Dutch if you know
what you're doing them it's quite
dangerous Queenie to is the the move
here now quindi force the old
continuation this is not so dangerous in
comparison so on what is going on here
um how do I continue interesting f force
also move that i'm not sure that i was
so mad probably it it is displayed but
if i take okay let's let's take this I
mean of course you can you can play
something like you will play neither
three obviously but the question is what
if I if I if I take this now what's this
this to weakening and weakening is
probably at the wrong word i mean is
this some giving up to too many 10p I
could play just if five I mean this is
also possible a team come on 95 I can
take g5 so he needs to take on pass on
now or um or move the Queen basically
and I don't think you want to move the
Queen then I'm certainly just much
better just extra porn and not much
going on besides that ok so now do I
want to take g5 first on saitek g5 and
then after he he retakes
some other moves than taking on e6
taking only 60 can take da denied f7 so
this doesn't make any sense grabbing the
night the the bishop dough is would be
really nice I mean what if i take and
play h 6 i-10 g6 is very weak okay so
let's just let's just play it simple and
recapture this means I'm gap I map upon
this is six pawn which is not the
strongest porn ever but it's upon and
I'm intending to grab the bishop on g5
and with two bishops on on a wide open
board I should have pretty decent
chances the thing is what is he doing
now he can't exchange Queens on d 8 and
just cancel long I mean this is probably
close to compensation maybe this
compensation the pawn is not easy to
convert and he's got or pieces active
just take on the aid and Castle long but
of course he can also try out of things
Queen a4 check on Queen III something
like that but if you move the Queen then
um definitely we have definitely give up
the bishop iam so if i take with them
the night now I've I don't attack g5
anymore I don't want to do that and the
night it's not bad on f7 anyway it's
covering much many many good squares and
this list doesn't look too bad I have I
have Bishop d6 as a possible next smooth
ok so now I could actually take him ok
let's let's first develop 26 not be five
I could take and I'm actually
threatening not g5 and you should f4
check winning
winning a piece okay so this is a
retreat this might be five an annoying
move for a bit I could play a 60 why not
come on let's go by six control the
square and my next move can be rupee aid
so how to continue 94 I'm not sure not
deform attacking insects can be an issue
should I go with C 5c 5 and King c7 come
on the night on f7 is really doing a
good job it controls g5f 7 and g5 d5 and
d6 from f7 okay yeah okay we can try to
pile up on them only six of course mmm
slightly annoying can take and then I
probably need to play this move try to
get the Bishop of the six phone yeah
what now Bishop to c7 he probably can
take e 6 cm but wait wait wait he cannot
take it six Bishop e6 rookie 6 and then
he takes his seven okay
okay i can i can go here anyway so not
shouldn't be a big problem oh i didn't
didn't think about that move okay I'm
Bishop e7 I can play Bishop c6 I think
you know this is maybe better Wow Bishop
fc3 checker I'm such a fool just I can
play just King evade or something and
not much is happening with bishops III
now yeah maybe it's not such a big deal
okay if I phys got even look at for this
was stupid he's just exchanging
everything down it takes g7 at the end
and like a miracle is upon up from just
being upon down form for not much being
upon up you can only hope for some bad
technical play huh yeah okay it's a it's
simply upon I have no no big big trixia
right before maybe guys stop playing
very quickly the only a small
consolation here I'm warning well this
isn't even so easy
this is weird why would you repeat moves
here I mean is five seconds up okay yeah
well I'm glad to have managed it but
that doesn't make so much sense yeah of
course um he had a little bit of
compensation of course but I can just
play king of a tent that's basically not
much happening we can get ecigs back but
not term not much else just king of ATM
and it should be it should be equal now
can you f cking f 6 of course it's just
the geotech i mean it cannot go to g6
and e5 does rookie form and its really
really para singh alright thanks for
watching